millions of women across the u.s could
lose their legal right to abortion this
could be the most consequential opinion
in decades from the supreme court that
would overturn roe versus wade raises
questions about the future of roe versus
wade and what this means for abortion
rights in our country so this is
happening in the u.s right now and
lately i've been wondering why the
is there not a birth control pill for
men i mean it's 2022 we can make
vaccines in like 10 seconds we send
telescopes into space and we can take
photos of things millions of light years
away but yet we still have not figured
out how to make it so that i can take a
pill and not have a baby when i have sex
i mean we're kind of trying look at this
instagram ad that i got served it's like
a balsack ultrasound sperm killer pouch
device there's actually an appetite for
this people want it i polled all of you
of men are saying that they would be up
for taking a birth control pill so let's
talk about birth control first let's
start with a list of the options you
have if you want to have sex and not
have a baby there's like ten options for
women and two for men
two condoms and vasectomies oh and i
guess pulling out question mark oh and
of these two one is notoriously
unreliable and the other one is like
permanent none of these require us to
take something on a regular basis put
something in our bodies permanently or
affect our hormones in any way it's not
the 1950s anymore why is the burden of
birth control still predominantly on the
partner who carries the pregnancies we
got to the bottom of this through a lot
of reporting and i want to show you what
the deal is because in this story you
will see the dark side of medicine and
why some things get studied and why
others don't but you'll also see a bit
of hope in the future like this is
slowly changing not fast enough though
oh and i'm going to dive into sex ed
because
the details are kind of fuzzy for me
it's been a while
[Music]
the uterus becomes richly supplied with
blood to nothing
one sperm succeeds in breaking through
okay hold on
[Music]
welcome to sex ed class
okay we're all adults i know we know how
sex works and things but if you're like
me you kind of don't remember the
details so i just want to quickly go
over a couple things that to me as an
adult are really relevant to this
discussion first let's talk about
hormones
hormones are chemicals but there's so
much more than that so let's think of it
as an analogy here this is your body and
all of the veins and arteries are the
internet this is how stuff gets around
hormones are like emails that are sent
from the managers of the body all of
these glands the managers are telling
different parts of the body what to do
to change something to kick off some
certain process or behavior all in the
name of keeping the body balanced and
regulated and healthy everything from
digestion to stress to sleep to mood all
of this is dictated by hormones these
emails being sent around your
bloodstream in the form of chemicals to
tell your body what to do okay so that
is hormones now let's talk about how
babies are made if it's fertilized by a
male sperm cell it'll grow into a baby
the doctor lends a helping hand and the
new baby meets the outside world every
month a woman's body managers send out
some really important emails remember
emails are hormones we're just gonna
stick with the analogy okay the hormones
tell this big bag of eggs to release one
of the eggs down this tube so that it
can end up here in the uterus the uterus
which has already received its own set
of emails saying that the egg is on its
way and please prepare the place so that
it's cozy by putting this nutrient-rich
lining like a nice cozy blanket so that
the egg has the best chance of thriving
so the egg finally arrives and hopes
that a male sperm will join it so that a
baby can start growing for the next nine
months but if the sperm doesn't arrive
on the scene within like this really
narrow time period it's like a day then
the hormone managers send another set of
emails saying
too bad so sad he didn't show up we're
not reproducing this month let's clear
all this lining out that we created for
the egg and start preparing for next
month they clear it all out they flush
out all this bloodlining while the woman
is on her period and the cycle starts
over do you see how this entire thing
plays out because of very specific
instructions that are written and sent
by hormones they cue each step of this
process okay but most of the time you
just kind of want to have sex and not
have the egg and the sperm meet up right
even though the body really wants that
you don't necessarily want to have a
baby and this is why we invented birth
control the most effective of these is
the pill don't forget to take your pill
i won't
pause really quick i just need to tell
you something which is one of the
questions i get most often is how do you
know so much about all of these random
topics like male birth control
the answer is because i read a lot of
books actually no i don't read a lot of
books because i'm super dyslexic and i
don't have time to sit and read books i
listen to a lot of audiobooks which
brings me to thanking today's sponsor
which is audible this is really easy for
me because i've been using audible for
like a decade for someone who loves
information but struggles to read either
because it's hard for me to read or
because i just don't have time to sit
and read audible has changed my life
when you subscribe to audible you get to
choose one title a month of any type of
audiobook you also get unlimited access
to their audible originals which are
only available to audible members i
often just scroll through here and say
like what do i want to listen to for
free there's so much good stuff
currently listening to an audiobook from
one of my favorite science explainers
bill bryson it's called the body it's a
really well-written science explainer
book about the human body and every
system it like gives you a new
appreciation for your body it allows me
to research and learn about new things
so i can make videos for all of you you
can try this out for free if you want
you can have an entire month free all
you need to do is go to the link in my
description it's audible.com johnny
harris or text johnny harris to 500 500
and get signed up for a month of free
audible thank you audible for supporting
this video let's dive back in
okay most modern methods of birth
control work by messing around with the
emails being sent around the body cue
the pill so a woman takes this little
pill every day where's the pill i have a
pill this is the pill actually it's 28
pills because a woman takes this every
single day and it changes everything the
pill contains a new batch of emails or
hormones that override the old
instructions and tell the whole system
to do something totally different
announcement for the next 28 days we're
under new management so the new emails
are coming down to the ovaries where all
the eggs are and they're like hey guys
don't do anything this month you're fine
just relax take a nap and the ovaries
are like but
that means we won't get anything done
we're gonna be super unproductive we're
like the most important thing for
keeping the species alive and the pills
are just like take a nap go to sleep
okay here comes another email this time
it's going to the cervix telling it to
start making really thick sticky mucus
and the cervix is like but wait we make
mucus that isn't thick and we actually
try to make it so it's perfect so that
the sperm can swim upstream and get to
the egg and the pills are just like
do what you're told oh and uterus change
the lining that you're creating so that
it's not very cozy for an egg to survive
in case you know one gets through and
the uterus does and this is how the pill
works it writes new emails it sends new
hormones to tell this whole system to do
something totally different than what it
was programmed by evolution to do to
keep our species going and it totally
works if you want to have sex and not
have a baby take this pill every day
and there's the downside you have to
take this pill every day and that comes
at a cost
it turns out that changing the hormones
that make it so that this doesn't happen
also has some side effects because
hormones are not isolated to one system
they don't just affect this you mess
with hormones you mess with all the
systems it's an interconnected thing
that changing the level of one can
affect many others but listen who am i
to talk about this i've never taken this
pill i've never been on any sort of
hormone treatment so let's talk to
people who actually have i had never had
a panic attack before i rarely had
anxiety
when i started taking birth control
literally everything made me anxious i
had
very oppressive and debilitating
depression to the extent i've never felt
before i would look in the mirror and
wouldn't recognize myself my brain felt
like mush i didn't realize how much it's
changing me how much it affects me
until i stopped taking it so i only felt
real me once i stopped taking the birth
control definitely the worst part was
the emotional toll i felt like a
different person i was constantly upset
i got angry i was crying because of the
pill i developed this giant blood clot
inside of my uterus and i had to get it
removed hormonal birth control was in
some ways really awesome but at the same
time i didn't have a sex drive and i
started birth control before i started
having sex so i really thought that
there was something wrong with me it was
a very dark time in my life and when i
went to the doctor i asked if the birth
control pill
could contribute to that and i was
basically laughed at it is so
frustrating to deal with side effects
that mess with your mood and with your
feelings because it's so easy to just
internalize that and to gaslight
yourself into thinking that this is just
the way you are now i guess i'm just
moody
i guess i'm just grumpy all the time and
it's hard to take a step back and
to
think am i going through a hard time
or are these side effects from my birth
control pill it was like a roller
coaster for two years what you don't
know is like you when you go off your
hormones are crazy like you shed hair
like crazy like i was pulling out clumps
of hairs like is something wrong with me
and you google it and you're like oh no
that's normal that'll last for like six
months to a year i mean this is a very
widespread well-known well-documented
thing a study from denmark found that
women who take the pill that has
hormones in it are more likely to suffer
depression compared to women who don't
and again this isn't just like once a
month this isn't just like every once in
a while this is every single day you are
putting this hormone modifying thing
into your body and is it surprising that
some women have really serious effects
with this i mean the pill is tampering
with arguably the most biologically
important system we have okay but really
quick before you like demonize the pill
the pill is amazing and it's totally
safe 150 million women take it every day
and for a lot of women it actually helps
regulate some of their hormones that are
off balance so if you have questions
about birth control and hormones don't
listen to a random dude on youtube go
talk to a health care professional thank
you i want to get to male birth control
eventually like that's the reason you
clicked on this video that's the purpose
we're going there i'm going to explain
male birth control but to get there we
have to understand where this pill came
from and the price that women had to pay
to get it and then we can all sit around
and ask ourselves would men be willing
to pay that price to get a pill of their
own so let's talk about where this magic
pill came from well before playing
around with hormones humans were still
trying to have consequence-free sex and
they basically had one tool available to
them which was some form of condom
sometimes it was linen sometimes it was
animal intestines or in japan they used
tortoise shells
wait what tortoise shells
oh tortoise shells wow that's a great
fitting tortoise shell what kind of
tortoise is this anyway this is what
they used once the material latex was
invented condoms became very cheap and
widely available but you have to
understand that for a long time they
weren't trying to not have kids they
were trying to stop diseases from
spreading but you don't get them if you
use a condom because you know children
are a blessing from above why would you
want to not have them let me see what
you have
no but then women in the modern age
heaven forbid wanted to have fewer
children but they still wanted to have
sex and unfortunately a top way of doing
that was through dangerous and deadly
back alley abortions so in 1916 this
nurse from new york opened a clinic and
the theme of her clinic was birth
control teaching women how not to get
pregnant by the way this was like super
illegal at the time because under this
law you couldn't publish anything having
to do with sex so she's totally breaking
the law teaching women about sex geez
scandalous but she fought back and
eventually helped create planned
parenthood and it was her who led the
charge in creating the pill the thing
that uses hormones to stop reproduction
from happening and in the 60s this pill
would change everything equal rights to
have a job to have respect and not be
viewed as a piece of meat
women have a fundamental right to
control their own bodies to control
their own lives women could now have
autonomy over their bodies they could go
to work and earn money for themselves
and decide for themselves when they
wanted to have children she was a hero a
liberator
and she was totally racist orally she
spoke about it in a very racist parlance
referring to it as a tool to help quote
the process of weeding out the unfit and
preventing the birth of defectives i
mean that's more than racist that's
called eugenics this was a popular
pseudo-scientific movement at the time
that was all about breeding a superior
race and eradicating the unfit which
these people were able to deem whoever
they wanted poor people people of color
immigrants people with disabilities all
of them were to be weeded out so a kind
of inconvenient fact in all of the story
is that a major motivation for the pill
wasn't sexual liberation but rather it
was the overpopulation of the earth with
these unfit races and peoples but
nonetheless the development of the pill
went forward and they decided to do
trials on it to get it ready for market
and where did they turn but puerto rico
a place where all problems were blamed
on overpopulation a perfect testing
grounds for this really twisted f'd up
project of weeding out unfit races
puerto rico a beautiful little island
with a big problem in 1956 contraceptive
pills 20 times as strong as the ones
used today were first tested among
puerto rican women who lived in
government housing projects in puerto
rico they were already sterilizing women
to control the population and now they
were going to test out this new
experimental pill they pitched them like
hey come do the pill instead of getting
sterilized because they were literally
forcing people to get surgery where they
tie the tubes and they like make it
impossible to have kids they started
giving them the pill oh but they forgot
to tell them that they were part of a
trial for a highly experimental drug
that was going to mess with their
hormones
[Music]
these doctors didn't have their dosing
figured out yet so they were giving
women pills that were way more
hormonally aggressive than the ones we
have today so these women were
experiencing intense side effects but
the doctors running the trial told the
new york times that these side effects
were quote largely psychogenic most of
them happening because women expect them
22 women dropped out of the study
because of the side effects and three
women died
but their deaths were never investigated
but in the end the trial was deemed a
success eventually they dialed in the
dosage and the pill hit the market and
that's how we got the birth control pill
i wish it was a better story like i wish
there wasn't the whole eugenics puerto
rico thing i was it was just like some
badass feminist was like we're gonna
have less kids and we invented this pill
because we can and we're liberated but
that's just not how it happened it's a
reminder that something so liberating
can also be oppressive and that's just a
contradiction we're all gonna have to
live with because life is complicated
anyway today the pill is the most
popular birth control method at least
here in the us i was looking at cdc data
but now we've got other options too like
there's this little t that women can put
in their uterus for up to 10 years and
it can either release hormones to kind
of do the same thing or it can be
wrapped in copper which kills sperm no
hormones at all it's 99 effective and
the second most popular form of birth
control and the third most popular is a
condom which of course doesn't release
any hormones and does not get ingested
into our bodies and it is kind of our
one birth control method that we have as
men
in addition to a vasectomy like those
are our choices that's what we've got
and that is my question that is the
heart of why i made this video which is
like why is all of the tampering with
the hormones to prevent baby's thing
a female thing why didn't this history
happen to men why don't we have a pill
that sends overriding emails to our
balls or something well of course
there's the obvious unquantifiable
reality that the people holding the
power and the money and wearing the lab
coats have always been men who get to
decide what to research and what to
focus on oh and that controlling women's
bodies has somehow always been
normalized and still is
exhibit a to draft supreme court opinion
showing a majority would overturn roe
versus what overturned the landmark roe
v wade and of course we live in a
society where women are responsible for
all things babies after all it grows in
their uterus
so it's not that surprising to me that
the scientists weren't out there
recruiting puerto rican men to
participate in some unethical study
about controlling their bodies and what
they can and can't do it's laughable to
think about that scenario because it
just would never happen but it would be
slightly a cop-out if i just left the
explanation at structural sexism which
is absolutely a thing it is real but
there are some other explanations for
why we don't have a male birth control
pill let me break those down for you and
then let me show you what options we
dudes do have which is kind of cool like
there's some really cool emerging stuff
so let's look into it
but i was wondering why there's so many
sperm cells and only one egg cell
here
maybe a diagram will help the major
legitimate limitation is biology it's a
lot easier to stop one egg a month than
it is to stop 180 million sperm blasting
out of you every time you ejaculate
blasting is that slightly too aggressive
anyway that's a lot to manage but
scientists are working on it and making
progress one of the most promising
studies we found in our reporting was
not a birth control pill but a hormonal
gel this is not a pill it's actually a
gel that's applied daily to a man's arm
or shoulder and local researchers think
this could be it in men who've used it
as directed there have been no little
surprises the hormones tell your body to
stop producing sperm and it works really
well in trials the trials are being
tested in dozens of places around the
world and it's definitely the furthest
along of all of the things we looked at
and they're actually looking for more
couples to participate in the trial so
if you want to participate go into the
description and check it out i would
participate but in full disclosure and
probably tmi for the internet i have two
children and i'm done having kids so i'm
gonna get a vasectomy that's a story for
another day
there's another method that scientists
are testing called ryzig you get a shot
in the groin i know it sounds terrible
but you're probably numb and fine and
the gel from the shot blocks the sperm
from passing
research is saying that the gel can last
for 13 years and that if you want to
dissolve it you just do a second
injection and it dissolves it was
originally developed in india but some
american companies have licensed the
technology and are developing similar
projects but it's still pretty early and
lastly there are of course pills that
are being tested there are a lot of
different approaches to these pills some
of them are hormonal like the birth
control pill that was racistly developed
in puerto rico sending new emails to sex
organs to get them to not do the thing
they're used to doing but some of these
pills don't use hormones at all but
rather a chinese herb that changes the
shape of the sperm's head to make it a
worse swimmer so that it can't reach the
egg it's so funny to me to think of like
we got too good at like procreating and
now we want to stop it but evolution's
like dude we've been trying so hard to
make this easier stop changing the
sperm's head to look like a hook there's
another pill that cuts off the special
protein found in the testes that then
stops the sperm production it's like all
these clever ways of like reprogramming
the body it's been 99 effective at
preventing pregnancies in mice and the
moment they stop taking it they bounce
right back to normal fertility very
promising
on mice clinical trials on humans are
supposedly going to start this year like
progress but do you notice it's like
it's 2022 we've invented all of this
amazing stuff and we're still in early
trials like early trials of all of these
inventions like we weren't doing this in
the 70s or the 80s when they were in
puerto rico messing with people we're
doing it now i mean a lot of these drugs
like have a decade to go before they're
even close to viable to sell and that
has a lot to do with how we think about
side effects for men hear me out on this
this is like the most important part of
this entire video and if you were still
here watching just hear me out side
effects for men there was one study that
was cancelled because the safety board
deemed the side effects too severe even
though 75 of the participants said that
they would keep going that the side
effects weren't too bad they cancelled
it and what were these side effects
feelings of depression mood swings
acne
hmm
sound familiar
a woman experiencing mood swings and
depression on a pill is now totally
normalized happens every day to millions
of women and we're okay with it because
you know it's a small price to pay to
prevent a giant thing like a child
growing inside of you but if a healthy
man experiences the same or similar
volatile side effects
we deem it as too severe unacceptable
not enough benefit for the cost of those
side effects all of this means that
experimentation and male birth control
is limited which means that no one wants
to fund it no companies want to invest
in it it gets chump change in terms of
funding like the entire pharmaceutical
industry invested 13 million into
contraceptive research between 2018 and
2020. the former ceo of just one pharma
company made more than double that
amount in just one year alone like we're
talking pennies goes into this because
it does not have long-term viability
and this is the big failure to me it's
how we frame our acceptance of side
effects for men that is at the root of
all of this if two people are engaged in
consensual sex and one of them gets
pregnant then both should be equally
affected
that seems like a no-brainer that is an
obvious thing to say but we all tacitly
disagree with that when we deem a
woman's risk as higher and thus we have
a higher tolerance for her side effects
but that's how it is the partner who
carries the pregnancy takes on the role
of birth controller even at the expense
of the hormonal balance of their body
which affects so much more than just
their eggs in their tubes and it won't
change until we men step
up and start seeing birth control as
something that we both carry together
the good and the bad regardless of our
anatomy
your students who've been watching this
film you've heard the questions we're
going to discuss
you can discuss these same questions
with your teacher but
there goes my uterus
my pressures okay